well Peter chapters on a Twitter pages
becoming a new battleground after that
violent rally in Charlottesville
Virginia over the weekend the five-year
old page is dedicated to calling out
racism now it's shifting its focus to
exposing white supremacist who gathered
over the weekend Kris Van Cleave is at
the statue of Robert Ely in
Charlottesville the city's effort to
remove that statue is what led to the
weekend protests in the first place
Chris good morning to you good morning
this park was full of white supremacist
protestors over the weekend many of them
weren't covering their faces they
weren't trying to hide their identities
but we're still largely anonymous one
man is trying to use his Twitter page to
change that he wants to not only name
them but to shame them the protests in
Charlottesville were angry violent and
deadly we saw more white supremacists
attend the rally in Charlottesville than
we've seen in over a decade many
demonstrators also seemed unconcerned
about being exposed they're not wearing
masks anymore they're not wearing their
hoods they're not afraid anymore Logan
Smith who runs the Twitter account yes
you're racist decided they did not
deserve to be anonymous on Saturday he
started posting photos of protesters on
his Twitter page as his followers jumped
from fewer than 65,000 to about 350,000
they started helping him put names to
faces I was able to go through those
public profiles look at more pictures to
determine you know that they were in
fact the same person for many this man's
image has come to symbolize Friday
night's rally yes you're racist
identified him as Peter Seve autonomous
a student at the University of
nevada-reno I do now identify as a white
supremacist or a racist of course that
that definition is really fluid people
have one version I have another I'm all
right because I'm Pro white it's not
just Twitter that's led to the outing of
Charlottesville protesters after the New
York Times posted this photo of James
Alex Fields jr. the man accused of
killing a woman when he slammed his car
into counter protesters the man standing
next to him was soon identified on
social media as Nigel krofta he's now
lost his job at an equipment supply
company I'm running in my head
how am I gonna get money now but don't
phase me nothing chases me experts say
the current political environment may
make it difficult to shame extremists
when you have white supremacists and
those who are violent feeling
comfortable in society today that's a
danger and the extremists expert we
talked to said white supremacists see
this moment in time as what they hope
will be the start of a white civil
rights movement and the rhetoric is
escalating both the man behind the
Twitter page and some of the people he's
identified say they've been receiving
death threats Norah Chris thank you very
interesting how that you know they're
there they're in a public rally with
cameras and now they're sort of names
are being tied to their face and they
don't mind being seen I think that that
takes it to a whole different level from
the whole they're trying to make this a
movement to